hello and welcome to PlayStation great
it's been two weeks since our last meet
up to go over all the fortnight battle
royale map updates so let's jump in
right now and put that right like usual
sit your butt down and relax for between
five and 10 minutes
slap Konohamaru in the shop to support
this series and let's relive Christmas
and New Year in fortnight chapter 2
[Music]
we're starting with the big event the
new year's event well it's more of a
mini event which happened every single
hour for a whole day so you probably
watched it but if you missed it cuz you
have a real life don't worry I've got
your back I have no life here's what you
missed
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we all danced and watched balls drop
it's kind of like a metaphor for life
[Music]
over the last 14 days Epic Games has
given us a gift to open every single day
from Han Solo's Millennium Falcon to an
ice woolly mammoth outfits did you
notice though that the items are slowly
filling up the lodge here's what it
looked like before and after it's these
little touches which are damn awesome
they really are outside the island was
completely covered in snow including the
beach but sadly no frozen rivers but one
thing nobody asked for turned up
uninvited a freaking snowstorm in every
single game making visibility impossible
out of interest were you a fan of this
I'll be looking in the comments to see
if you liked random weather effects in
fortnight battle royale on Christmas
date more ice sculptures began to pop up
like the gingerbread igloo this time we
had small ice huts like the one looking
over the farm and there was also this
big-ass chair which must be a homage to
the original chair from chapter 1 all
those seasons ago if you saw the
original chair on the original fortnight
map please write in the comments chair I
was there let's see how many people are
old jeez
in addition to all this big stuff there
were tiny tiny my new little things
which kept us all coming back and get
this we may have the beginnings of a
brand new story a brand new sub story
maybe it's even as good as the rock
people do you remember that ah Rock the
Dwayne Johnson Sharon Stone Kid Rock
those were the days anyway let's go back
a few weeks to set the scene with
Christmas coming the log jam factory was
taken over with Christmas cheer the
gingerbread men moved in to craft gifts
for azan the delivery truck arrived
outside but hidden in the pallets was a
misfit present thrown out like it was
trash the half-breed bear doll looked
inanimate but I thought I'd check on him
just in case a few weeks later and when
I got there this well actually when I
got there the bloody New Year thing
happened again so I had to dance around
like an idiot but once that finished I
could check that the misfit Teddy had
gone where the heck could he have gone
so my mission was to find the misfit
Teddy and his pals remember the upturned
truck to the west of log jam well there
were toys strewn everywhere but this
week things have changed
the misfit toys are leading a mutiny
deliberately crashing the wagon last
week and now forming a secret misfit
Society right in front of our eyes but
mouthing us from the shadows the toy
uprising of 2020 is confirmed we what do
you have two choices now do we wait and
see what the misfit cult do or do we
Metal Gear Solid stealth assassinate
them right now
[Music]
damnit copyright claims I'll change the
music to something even more epic and
free
[Music]
I regret nothing going back to the log
factory I started to wonder where the
gingerbread workers went once their
shift was over
you know once Christmas was done maybe
they vanished into thin air well get
this I found them they are up at Ferris
Bueller's house a quick recap the red
car was first found here in the garage
or garage if you prefer to say it like
that before it fell from the cliff in
the movie there are three people
watching that car as it fell and look
now those three people have been
recreated by gingerbread men and watched
their beloved Porsche fall to its demise
it's likely just an easter egg nod to
the scene or maybe they pushed it over
the edge we need revenge I really need
to stop doing that I've got I've got
issues
to calm this down a bit we also confirm
that the Christmas tree we saw on the
flatbed trucks last week finally made
their way to craggy cliffs and yes the
swamp got one too what a touching moment
it got me thinking how will these things
leave the island will they be taken away
gradually in-game or will they just
vanish I hope it's the former latter
former first one former I hope it's the
former okay okay my favorite update of
the season so far has happened remember
the old iron man made of pieces of pipes
sat dormant on the cliff edge back in
week one well well he hasn't moved but
this week he got into the Christmas
spirit
check out these glasses given to him on
Christmas Day that is a sexy mother
trucker right there I know it's not a
big update but yeah this this definitely
is my favorite this week let's just sit
and watch this for 10 seconds
in nomemes am i trying to pub this video
to send myth it's moving on here's a
massive one you've probably seen did you
travel over to softie Springs this week
it's always been one of the most
Christmassy places on the island but
something really weird really strange
happened this week the Snowman FBI
showed up and smashed someone's
backdoors in well it's the friend Darby
beefy old enough you get that joke the
house is literally filled with snowmen
that showed up in government vehicles
from Chapter one it's likely another
movie reference or maybe a new meme
strategy for players as there's so many
snowmen to hide inside but look at the
devastation walls smashed furniture
overturned chests floating I think
you're drunk a fortnight let's see if
this is a one week wonder or if it's a
storyline maybe it could even link into
the misfit society in the swamp time
will tell ok one last thing I want to
ask you this is likely nothing but here
goes while searching the island I went
back to camp Cod can you confirm that
this seat was here from week one I
really can't remember and more
importantly was the image of area 51 you
know that the divet was that here all
along too if not why is this seat
looking out to the sea is this a message
I'm too dumb to understand or simply an
easter egg from the old island no change
at the bunker but it's all wintery and
snowy and lovely yeah but but seriously
no change
[Music]
other things of note include risky reals
returning to its original layouts the
Star Wars event has vanished overnight
but at least we have the memories to
cherish
especially the return of hot watch which
is now confirmed to being in Star Wars
Canon yeah if you believe that you
believe anything and the lightsabers
were damn cool too weren't they I do
hope they make their way to creative so
many minigames we could make with those
bad boys make it happen epic a few modes
will rename this week and the changes
included an epileptic fit
whenever you joined battle labs happy
days and if you're thinking Adam where
the heck is a story theory it is ready
but I'd like to wait until we have the
secret skin next week because that will
make it even better so please hold on
it's worth the wait I promise we have
like speed boat chases and and bunker
watch shenanigans watch this space so I
think we're done here Christmas 2019 is
in the history books New Year 2020 has
been and gone so cherished the memories
and let's move on
so that's where we are after the
Christmas and New Year update in for
tonight Battle Royale
like always hit me up on Twitter if I've
missed anything my name is Adam grenade
over there and I'll add it next time
thank you to everyone who rocked my cold
over the festive period you guys make
this series possible and i truly
appreciate what you do for me everything
you've done in 2019 thank you so much
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade happy
new year everyone
2020 he's gonna be great see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]